I couldn't even imagine that I will be
working abroad
I came from the Philippines it is a
situation that you either the domestic
work for prostitution than some other
woman Widow it's a very difficult
situation but you have to choose between
a life that will give your children
chance to survive and maybe we'll have a
better future you don't have that much
clearer picture it's only a dream a
beautiful dream
justice for domestic workers is a
self-help group or migrant domestic
workers campaigning for our rights in
the UK we are trying to cope up with
everything we still work in campaign and
lobby for policy to change
elissa guys we were trying to make it
faster for you who are already working
long hours you don't have time to really
review especially the life in the UK if
you lost your employer you need to find
employer as soon as possible okay many
are losing their job today I'll be Sonia
the gap okay
seeing my fellow domestic workers I
started to help them and I did feel that
they needed someone that could
understand that it could fill them I
didn't know that there are many of them
who couldn't read who couldn't drive
sometimes those who've been badly beaten
and some who have been raised
we need to be very careful in fighting
the employer if you get to live have
enough calm down calm down okay if we
can settle the employer peacefully we
will settle that employer peacefully so
they don't do anything against you
because you know the UKB
always believe the employer's they don't
really believe you she's not receiving
her on a holiday and I could see the
employer produce documents aah is
self-employed worker and actually under
the domestic worker this domestic
workers couldn't be self-employed but of
course we are more on selling this
peacefully if we can because we know one
part of a side job
Biderman heartedness resign status which
is very much dependent on them for years
under the old system the domestic
workers and private household have right
to change employer if the domestic
workers were being abused
there was escape route available in the
new system they don't have the right to
change employer the consequences of
ability to change the policy you tie the
domestic workers and one employer and
does the slavery
I'm going to pick when domestic worker
so just ran away
she's calling me after I need that I'm
already in the bus okay so just stay
where you are
once they decided to run away then we do
offer some shelter so it's a busy day
but this is something I can that I have
to do first
emergency rescue operation which exactly
yeah okay
okay thank you
you have no other things no you're my
password with me
your password is video good let's go
this morning I pick her up and then I
haven't told her anything after a
because I feel so sad of telling her the
current situation before 2012 you can
change employer okay and if you run out
your visa as long as you have employer
to renew your visa you can renew your
visa here in the UK that's all gun now
you say you're so sad you're very scared
don't worry that's nothing that's
nothing much we can do okay it's okay
it's okay
something also I don't want to tell you
when I just first see you precise so you
have so much hope many here I like you
meaning you're not alone okay happy okay
we were happy we are here don't worry we
are campaigning for all of you okay
but we also need you to help us okay
please all right we can win this and
that is the only hope
if I do anything
the face the face
to show the humans
I feel like
I don't know she has also some
I'm very much looking forward
the disappointingly world does nothing
up early in the bill for the domestic
workers suppose when they say about
prevention and protection they actually
most of the best prevention of
protection of the domestic office which
is the domestic worker visa the overseas
domestic worker visa then imagine my
life to be this way
the reality to my real water can cook
we're up and
snooty shamed my family to meet our
shadow when you leave for Thailand wish
to Nashua